[Música]
ah
se confirma la victoria de joe biden en
arizona y en georgia después del
reconteo en este estado bailén ahora
tiene 306 votos electorales muy por
encima de los 270 necesarios para llegar
a la presidencia según el 'new york
times' las mujeres los afroamericanos
los latinos y las personas en las
ciudades votaron más por byd en los
hombres blancos los evangélicos y
aquellos que viven en áreas rurales
votaron más por donoso el voto en los
suburbios fue el que más cambio y el que
terminó dándole la victoria a bailén
según el 'times' las encuestas también
fueron grandes perdedoras porque muchas
de ellas daban hasta un 10 por ciento de
ventaja a bailén pero el resultado de
las elecciones fue bastante más
ajustados las encuestas tampoco
acertaron en la carrera por el congreso
donde los demócratas si controlaban la
cámara de representantes pero el senado
todavía está en juego con dos sillas que
se definirán el próximo 5 de enero
en georgia fecha en la que podría
cambiar el balance de poderes en
washington
[Música]
el presidente de donald trump se niega a
reconocer su derrota y continúa
avanzando en esa batalla legal para
intentar darle la vuelta a los
resultados electorales pero lo cierto es
que desde el comité electoral aseguran
que no hay evidencias de fraude en estas
elecciones y desde su propio partido
republicano cada vez son más las voces
que piden al mandatario estadounidense
que facilite una transición pacífica
donald trump lejos de hacerles caso
continúa avanzando legalmente y a estas
17 acciones legales que ya había
iniciado se suman ahora cinco demandas
más en pensilvania además en georgia ya
han comenzado a contar de nuevo de
manera manual más de cinco millones de
votos mientras tanto el presidente
electo joe biden continúa recibiendo las
felicitaciones por parte de los líderes
mundiales los últimos en felicitarle han
sido el papá francisco y también desde
china después de varios días de silencio
esa felicitación ha llegado a través de
un portavoz del ministerio de relaciones
exteriores
[Música]
con todas las miradas lógicamente
puestas en estas elecciones sobre quién
sería el próximo presidente también se
han pasado varias varios proyectos de
ley muy interesantes sobre todo aquí en
california y es que por ejemplo la
propuesta 22 ha sido votada a favor con
una mayoría de 60% en california y es
que esta propuesta proponía convertir
bueno evitar que una ley que entró en
vigor el año pasado pudiese convertir a
los empleados a los conductores de uber
y liszt en empleados a tiempo completo
uber y leaf apoyaron la propuesta número
22 para repeler esta ley y lograr seguir
manteniendo a sus conductores como
freelance y no tener que pagarles
beneficios hay que comentar también que
esta ley en general esta propuesta
perdón si tenía una mayoría de apoyo
entre los propios conductores de uber y
del leaf que querían seguir
manteniéndose como freelance de hecho
muchas miradas también estaban puestas
en este estado para ver qué ocurría con
este proyecto de ley ya que se en
general todo lo que suele pasar en
california también se suele
a medida que pasan los años en el resto
del país
[Música]